hallo ihr lieben heute möchte ich mit
euch über meinen schwarzkümmelöl reden
beziehungsweise über schwarzkümmelöl
allgemein weil ich denke und ich bin mir
eigentlich ziemlich sicher dass wir sehr
sehr viel bewirkt haben gerade in dem
bereich ich habe super viel
aufklärungsarbeit geleistet gerade so
bei meinem letzten video das vor
eineinhalb jahren online kam und aber
auch dauerhaft und durchgehend über
instagram ich finde einfach dass das
thema so komplex ist das jetzt noch mal
so die am häufigsten gestellten fragen
hier beantwortet werden ich möchte mich
jetzt aber auch nicht all zu wiederholen
weil im ersten video gab es schon extrem
viele hilfreiche informationen für euch
daher wenn dieses video endet in der
endart einmal auf das erste video von
mir klicken und unbedingt anschauen und
ich sag's direkt vorne weg ich verstehe
bis heute nicht wie ein mensch kein
schwarzkümmelöl einnehmen kann so
überzeugt bin ich und ich glaube auch
ihr und daher gehe ich jetzt noch mal
auf eure fragen ein und anhand der
antworten werdet ihr merken ok krass
worauf warte ich warum nehme ich kein
schwarzkümmelöl ein ganz kurzer
faktencheck was ist jetzt
schwarzkümmelöl schwarzkümmelöl sehe ich
persönlich als meinem persönlichen immun
booster weil es einfach so viele also
unendlich viele positive eigenschaften
hat das ist quasi öl das aus der pflanze
initiative gewonnen wird das ist eine
pflanze die in ägypten wächst natürlich
auch in anderen ländern aber in ägypten
gibt es den echten schwarzkümmel
initiative die dort quasi ihren ursprung
hat und ich achte beim einer produktion
selbstverständlich auch streng
kontrolliertem biologischem anbau und
nicht nur das ist ja auch wichtig dass
wenn die samen zu uns kommen nach nrw
dass auch dort nochmal kontrolliert wird
und daher wird mein schwarzkümmelöl
quasi in einer regionalen ölmühle
gepresst und da 80 auch darauf dass das
wirklich schonend und langsam kalt
gepresst wird gibt auch kaltpressung da
wird es kalt gepresst weil vielleicht 40
grad ich achte darauf dass es bei mir
circa 35 grad sind dass alle nährstoffe
enthalten bleiben und uns da auch nichts
wichtiges verloren geht ich habe euch
auch beim letzten besuch in der
produktion einfach mal mitgenommen zu
viel für hansa dank an der stelle für
filme und
wir haben jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
die prozesse gezeigt es ist so also wir
kommen erst mal an der station mit dem
samen an kommen gerade aus kontrolliert
biologischem anbau aus ägypten die
werden dann natürlich noch mal grob
gefehlt hat und dann geht das ganze
durch die presse da habe ich euch ja
schon gesagt dass es so langsam und so
kalt gepresst wird dass es wirklich
tropfen für tropfen raus kommt und
wichtig ist mir auch noch an der stelle
zu sagen wenn man sich denn ok was
unterschreibt jetzt dein schwarzkümmelöl
von irgendeinem anderen x-beliebigen wir
könnten natürlich viel schneller pressen
ist es dann immer noch kalt gepresst
deklariert aber es ging natürlich viel
schneller ihr müsst euch vorstellen eine
250 milliliter flasche vor mir braucht
20 bis 25 minuten bis sie voll ist
natürlich wirkt sich das dann auch auf
die zeit diesen anspruch nimmt und ihr
willst natürlich alle zeit das geld ja
wir haben uns aber gedacht dass es uns
egal wir lassen es so wir wollen ist
wirklich schonend gepresst haben damit
wir auch alle wichtigen und
lebensnotwendigen aminosäuren alle
vitamin alle nährstoffe richtig schön in
einer flasche haben und jetzt kommen wir
auch direkt zur ersten frage die mir so
oft gestellt wurde was ist der
unterschied zwischen deinem gefilterten
dann ungefilterten schwarzkümmelöl wir
haben ja alle drei größen die 100 mm
reise größe die 250 milliliter flasche
und die 500 milliliter flasche einmal in
der version gefiltert und einmal
ungefiltert wenn ihr mich fragt ich
persönlich und auch hamza wir nehmen
immer das gefilterte öl das ist einfach
bekömmlicher dass es mich so scharfen
geschmack muss dazu sagen ich habe heute
noch eine nachricht bekommen und die
bekomme ich immer das allgemeinwohl sehr
gut zu trinken ist und man sich dass man
viel schlimmer vorstellt als es ist
sonne strand beim ungefiltert nun ist es
ganz einfach so dass die schwebt und
trübstoffe einfach noch enthalten sind
und daher ist auch so dass ich das am
unteren ende der flasche manchmal
absetzt und wenn er das ganze ausgeht
dann ist es natürlich klar wenn ihr
unfall am ende der flasche ankommen
merkt ihr was irgendwie das öl schwarz
rauskommt und das liegt einfach daran
dass sich halt diese steht und
treibstoffe die halt schwarz sind hier
unten abgesetzt haben wenn ihr
allerdings dann zwischendurch mal
durchschütteln und dann das öl ausgeht
dann ist das öl natürlich von anfang an
schon schwarz und ich muss dazu sagen
dass wenn die es nie schüttelt und ihr
trinkt isst und trinkt es um kommt hier
unten an dann schmeckt es hier unten
dann doch sehr scharf daher entweder
steigt er um auf direkt auf das
gefilterte öl oder bevorzugt und dann
schüttelt er halt immer kräftig und
deshalb dürft ihr euch manchmal nicht
wundern wenn ihr das ungefilterte öl
bestellt und ihr bestellt euch nachschub
dass die dann irgendwie dunkler ist also
dass das öl schwerzer ist es ist halt
ein naturprodukt das ist jetzt nicht wie
bei coca cola das beispiel aber das
schmeckt immer gleich ihr wisst ihrem
land schmeckt's gleich aber hier ist es
so dass es ein naturprodukt und daher
könnt ihr dann nicht immer erwarten dass
da immer die gleiche konzentration
ansteht und treibstoffen ist man sieht
bei unserem besuch auch ganz deutlich
hier ist einmal der filter und der wird
gerade ausgetauscht dass sich das ist
auch das tolle wenn man wirklich
regional herstellt und auch wirklich
immer wieder vorbeischauen kann man kann
selber qualitätssicherung machen man
sieht da läuft alles wunderbar und da
stehe ich zu 1000 prozent dahinter und
jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage
was ist gesünder gefiltert oder
ungefüllt hat und man sagt dem
ungefilterten öl nach es ist so ein
hauch von mehr an nährstoffen enthalten
aber ich glaube haben sie und ich sind
das beste beispiel dafür dass ihr auch
das gefilterte öl nehmen können weil ich
nehme mich zum beispiel schon seit über
dreieinhalb jahren haben wir glaube ich
schon länger und schaut euch das erste
video haben also ich mit meiner
schilddrüsenunterfunktion ich fühle mich
fitter denn je haben sie hat keine
grenzen setzt seine ganzen energien
losgeworden und wir nehmen nur das
gefilterte öl weil es eben geschmacklich
ein bisschen mehr da ist die frage die
mich jeden tag erreicht ist kann man das
öl auch während der schwangerschaft und
vor allem während der stillzeit
einnehmen zur schwangerschaft habe ich
mir im letzten video schon was gesagt
das öl wird wen fördert daher solltet
ihr eigentlich erst mal drauf verzichten
aber ich habe zwei freundinnen die das
ab der 38 schwangerschaftswoche
natürlich mit absprache des arztes
eingenommen haben weil die an ihm
wollten dass die venen kommen daher
immer mit dem arzt sprechen und wie
gesagt dann dürfte eigentlich nichts
dagegen sprechen während der stillzeit
ist es so dass er ja auch natürlich
während der schulzeit von den ganzen
nährstoffen profitiert es gibt keine eu
norm das ist das problem also
schwarzkümmelöl wurde erst so ich sage
mal den 1960 er jahren entdeckt und
daher es gibt schon hunderte von studien
aber nicht jede behandelt jedes thema
und daher ich darf euch rechtlich
gesehen gar nichts verraten aber ich bin
der persönlichen auffassung dass während
der stillzeit gerade dann die ganzen
wichtigen nährstoffe den körper gut tun
und dann komme ich auch schon zum
nächsten thema dürfen kinder das
schwarzkümmelöl
auch hier keine eu norm erwachsene
dürfen bis zu einem esslöffel am tag
einnehmen wenn man erkrankt ist wie zb
jetzt an corona gerne auch die dosis
steigern für zwei bis drei wochen aber
bei kindern ist es so ich kann nicht
sagen was meine schwägerin macht und man
sieht auch in dem einen blog das war
nicht ganz düster hat der haben sie auch
meinen nichten auch schwarzkümmelöl
gegeben meine schwägerin hat es mich so
gemacht dass die im kleinkindalter
wirklich nur so ein drittel teelöffel
gegeben hat und dann je älter sie wurden
in einem halben teelöffel wie viel hast
du denn dass sie nicht im ganzen
teelöffel und wir endlich getan
ja auf jeden fall daran könnt ihr euch
sehr gerne richten und genau das ist dem
thema kinder und schwarzkümmelöl auch
die frage kam oft hilft das
schwarzkümmelöl beim kinderwunsch und
das muss ich ganz klar bejahen wir haben
sogar zwei nach ich nicht ob ich find
sie wieder mit zwei nachrichten und
zurück geht es bei nachrichten wollte
ich dann von zwei zuschauern die
geschrieben haben durch das
schwarzkümmelöl hat ist dann tatsächlich
funktioniert und das kann er auch nur
sein weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen
schwarzkümmelöl ist ein zusammenspiel
aus wichtigen aminosäuren aus
mineralstoffen und vitaminen zb die
aminosäure arginin hilft bei
potenzstörungen wurde sogar nachgewiesen
ich finde euch übrigens quellenangaben
unten in die infobox und selen vitamine
wie selen helfen auch bei
potenzstörungen indem es quasi die
spermienbildung fördert und nebenbei
bemerkt auch super gut für alle die
schilddrüsenprobleme haben kommen wir zu
den kapseln auch da kann ganz auf die
nachfrage ist das jetzt die gleiche
wirkung also wird es jetzt genauso wie
das öl und an den kapseln heute ein jahr
ist vergangen jahr es ist das
schwieriger hier ist übrigens noch mal
geschützt dass ihr das auch mal sind es
hat ein jahr gedauert warum es ist gar
nicht so einfach öl in vegane cups hin
zu führen ohne dass sich die kapsel
hülle zersetzt und meistens bestehen
welche kapseln ja auch aus gelatine auch
aus fischer dakine darauf wollten wir
komplett verzichten ich glaube es gibt
schon mittlerweile ein paar nachzügler
aber wir warten ob ich unter einfach
eine der ersten die schwarzkümmelöl in
veganen katzen heraus waren die ersten
darauf bin ich sehr stolz nachzügler
gibt es natürlich immer aber ich kann
euch auch gerne mal hier ein einblick
zeigen wobei auch nur ganz
wenig weil ja es gibt solche maschinen
nicht oft auf der welt und umso stolzer
bin ich dass wir dieses produkt anbieten
können nach so viel zeit und natürlich
die frage was ist hier drin ganz einfach
das gleiche wie in den falschen hier ist
ganz einfach mein gefiltertes
schwarzkümmelöl drin und die dosierung
haben wir jetzt gesetzt auf zwei kapseln
am tag das ist wirklich nur eine
empfehlung ich persönlich würde ich cups
teilnehmen würde ich persönlich sechs
neben drei morgens und drei abends und
das entspricht dann so ungefähr einem
guten teelöffel ich glaube deswegen kam
auch die frage wie viele sich dann aber
zwei kapseln entsprechend noch gar nicht
den tagesbedarf von einem teelöffel bis
zu einem esslöffel mir war es einfach
wichtig dass ihr das öl regelmäßig
einnimmt und vielleicht ist für manche
ist es ein bisschen too much man sagt
okay jetzt sechs cups denn am tag das
ist mir ein bisschen zu viel dann nehmt
lieber weniger aber dafür beständig es
ist super wichtig auch allgemein ob
jetzt das öl ist oder die kapseln dass
sie ist tag für tag einnehmen auch
menschen mit schilddrüsen unterfunktion
so wie ich wir können ja auch nicht auf
einmal eine woche pausieren und ihre
schilddrüsen tabletten nicht nehmen
macht es wirklich tag für tag und dann
komme ich auch schon zu meiner nächst
frage in viele haben auch gefragt war
merke ich denn so die ersten erfolge
wann geht es mir besser dann bin ich
richtig vital oder man merke ich das
irgendwie eine krankheit zurück geht das
kann man so pauschal gar nicht sagen ich
persönlich habe mich fitter und wacher
gefühlt nach ca zwei bis drei wochen der
einnahme man sagt aber dass ihr wirklich
regelmäßig drei monate lange
schwarzkümmelöl einnehmen müsste
natürlich auch dauerhaft aber macht es
drei monate und schreibt mir dann ihre
erfahrungsberichte und an der stelle ein
kurzes shoutout an alle die meinen
schwarzkümmelöl regelmäßig einnehmen und
erfahrungen haben schreibt jedoch gerne
auch hier damit wie die auch hier unterm
video sammeln könnt bekommt seiner
privaten nachrichten auf instagram aber
ich würde natürlich auch freuen wenn ihr
hier und unter kommentiert es kam auch
sehr viele nachfragen wie haben sie
seine politik los geworden ist und der
stadt
haben wir
ja jetzt bist du ja erklären dass ich
dachte ich kann man reden aber also ich
habe den tag eine vielleicht cola
getrunken und
es war so ich dann wirklich kurz von ok
ich hab dir auch nie machen wollen er
sagt also ich hätte sowieso nicht
gemacht aus dem grund weil ich weiß dass
polizei wieder zurückkommen ich habe
spaß zurück genommen meine mutter mir
sinnvollen damals markt kommen das hilft
gerade auch für die atmung weil ich
hatte immer auch nasal geredet und man
das war immer voll auch durch die
allergie ich habe auch eine chronische
sinusitis ich weiß gar nicht ob die ich
noch habe aber ich glaub mal nicht sagt
ja die chronische diese musik ist es ja
so dass das eine entzündung ist die wo
quasi schlag immer wieder hier bild und
das bleibt ja quasi aufhängen und das
fließt halt nicht ab das wollen wir auch
dass ich vor ihm hatte und das hat es
nochmal bestärkt hat ist noch massiv
verschlimmert und dadurch habe sein okay
alles klar ich versuche mal
schwarzkittel auch meine nase
einzureihen ich muss auch sagen ich weiß
gar nicht ob das militär ihn nicht so
laut ist oder sollte aber ich habe es
gemacht ich hab mir jetzt mal ab und zu
eine rein geschrieben und habe auch
allgemein einfach schwarz können wir
genommen und mir und einfach mal hier so
passiert weil ich einfach so die
hoffnung hatte dass irgendwie die
schwarzkümmel inhaltsstoffe da reingehen
und diese musik ist dann quasi sozusagen
auflösen und ich muss sagen es hat
wirklich sehr sehr gut geholfen aber ich
muss auch sagen ich habe auch schon mal
zu mir genommen weil ich extreme
schlafstörung auch hatte durch den
ganzen stress ich war auf kurs von
burnout weil wir gerade den shop
gegründet hat und direkt auf sein und
umzu und aber ich habe ja noch neben dem
shop ja auch gearbeitet und das hat mir
alles sehr sehr viel druck bereit sodass
ich auch dass das schwarz kommt mir sehr
geholfen hat ich hatte dann keine geräte
mehr keine kopfschmerzen ich habe
erstmal geschlafen ohne probleme und das
war auch so ein punkt wo ich gesagt habe
heftig heftig heftig aber jetzt kommt
der scooter krasses effekt und das ist
wirklich heftig gewesen ich war im
urlaub da waren wir geben ihr geht und
wo die schwarzen herren drinks und ich
habe da auch sogar meinen spaß gegönnt
aber ist es nicht es sind zwei sachen
aufgefallen als ich dort war habe ich
einen kleinen sohn hat bekommen ich hab
mir das an ein gerät und ich habe auch
etwas mit mir das noch mal schnell
segment manager bei pigmentstörungen
gehabt so und habe ich mir ein gegeben
und da habe ich mir auch gefallen das
macht und ob sich ministerin weg
gegangen sind ich weiß nicht woran das
wirklich liegt dass es muss an
schwarz-grün chamber eingerieben weil
ich aber die hoffnung hat ich mich es
ist ein alleskönner also das kann alles
so das ist der zauber getränk von
asterix obelix
einfach genau so es hat mir wirklich
geholfen braucht meine pigmentflecken
loszuwerden also dass auch mal zu fragen
weil das haben auch ein paar tage
gefragt so und dann war ich kam ich aus
dem urlaub zurück gesagt und ich hatte
extremen druck im ort extremen
unsicherheit verbreiten wollen liegt
kann die seien dadurch zum abgang hat er
mir ins ohr rein guckt hat er gesagt ja
okay ich habe total paar tage vorher
immer mal die duschbrause immer
eingehalten weil ich meinen hut
saubermachen wollte macht es nicht mehr
eine gute idee macht das nicht auch mit
war sich sicher war es auch gar keinen
fall und er sagt jeder ist hier
verstopfte ohren deswegen das bisschen
druck hatte mit einem quasi irgend etwas
rausgenommen auch ganz eklige und jetzt
kommt erst ein paar gewesen sondern
natürlich auch meine nase rein gucken
einfach aus kontrolle und dann als er so
rein guckt da habe ich schon gesagt ja
ich weiß ich habe polypen es muss dir
entfernen lassen oder muss auch sagen
dass wir auch andere art als ich vorher
war und da sagt er mir so nee du hast
keine probleme mich so kann ich sein
denn hinter seinen anderen stapler geht
das voll tiefer sondern ich habe schon
so eine große nase geht dann noch tiefer
rein politische kamera durch und märkte
da sind keine politiker nicht so hey es
gar nicht sein und das macht ziemlich so
klick so ist so eng da frage ich den
arzt auch noch liegt das vielleicht
daran dass schwarzkümmel nehmen und
jetzt kommt der arzt ich wusste ich es
ist da habe ich kann also für mich doch
gar nicht nach arbeit aus aber das kasse
ist er hat ihn auf arabisch gesagt ja
ist halt jede kapiert was ihr den tod
und das war halt aus dem auslieferung
vom islam das schwarzkümmel jede
krankheit halte außerdem tod und für
mich war das ein punkt ist so krass ich
habe direkt mein handy gezückt hatte
erst mal angerufen
voll krass und dies das hat meine
familie direkt sparen nachricht
geschickt alle meine freunde geschickt
ist so eher leute das ist das ist heftig
ihr müsst es unbedingt nehmen und seit
dem zeitpunkt an muss schon sagen dass
meine ganze familie also mir in den
bauch wirklich dann 100 prozent glaubt
an und alle schwarz können eingenommen
haben und dass auch der poser ecke kurz
käme vor allem schwarzkümmel was wir
kontrollieren können wo wir wissen er
das ist gut wir haben ja auch etliche
vorher getrunken deswegen also haben
sagt danke für den exkurs das war
wirklich sehr spannend und ich glaube
dass ich noch ein bisschen mehr zu
erzählen
neben gehabt hätte ja alles möglich ist
alles auf meine allgemein dass ich auch
nie wirklich krank werde das ist auch
hätte ich bin werde nie wirklich krank
und zum thema wie sagt man jetzt corona
ich werde sich sagen dass es gegen
korona hält es gibt studien ja das ist
ging ohne hilft aber ich muss sagen ich
hatte bis jetzt heute toll noch nicht
corona gehabt also ich dass ich wüsste
und ich bin wirklich leute seit zwei
jahren beim arzt weil ich krank wurde
oder eben etwas also wenn ich mal kann
würde ein tag mehr nicht ja und ich muss
sagen dieses jahr war gar nichts heute
ganz kurz das schwenker weil da haben
sie vorhin über allergien gesprochen hat
allergiker haben ja ein enzym defekt und
daher sollten sie es recht ganz viele
ungesättigte fettsäuren zu sich nehmen
und davon haben wir im schwarzkümmelöl
reichlich und ihr könnt es dann erstens
vorbeugend nehme also vorbeugend gegen
über allergien oder wenn ihr allergien
haben dass sie quasi zurücktreten und
dass sie sie besiegt aber wichtig ist
bei auch wieder tägliche einnahme also
wirklich regelmäßige einnahme und dann
werdet ihr auch schnell besserung
bekommen zum thema corona wollte ich
auch unbedingt was sagen denn ich
verfolge jedes studie und ist haben
mittlerweile mehrere studien belegt
verlinkt solchen infobox dass das
enthaltene timo konin im schwarzkümmelöl
quasi die korona viren hemmen sich an
diese an wirkungsstelle an diese aci 2
rezeptoren die eben quasi dieses
bindeglied dafür sind dass die
coronaviren sich einnisten dass das
quasi gehemmt wird und ich persönlich
muss sagen auch wir und auch in der
familie ich allein für mein gewissen war
ich mitnehmen schwarzkümmelöl allein zu
diesen zeiten und schwarz bündelt wirkt
auch antiviral also das sowieso und ob
es jetzt in corona virus ist oder ein
anderes virus besser ist es man nimmt es
vorher ein unser ziel wenn man hat da
habe ich auch ganz viele
erfahrungsberichte zu bekommen dass der
verlauf weil patienten oder bei menschen
die schwarzkümmelöl einnehmen total
abgeschwächt ist und man eigentlich kaum
symptome hat zum thema kann es sich auch
positiv auf die psyche einwirken also
sprich depression oder auch nicht
depression einfach dass man vielleicht
niedergeschlagen ist und immer schlechte
laune hat ja kam es tatsächlich denn
schwarzkümmelöl greift positiv auf den
hirnstoffwechsel 1 ich weiß ich habe
wirklich deswegen immer so gut gelaunt
das wäre auch die antwort dafür oder
es gibt sogar eine studie die besagt
dass die zwei glückshormone serotonin
und dopamin durch die einnahme von dem
öl stärker freigesetzt werden und das
ist auch eine angstlösende wirkung hat
zum thema hormonhaushalt falls wir da
schwierigkeiten haben schwarzkümmelöl
kann auch den hormonhaushalt regulieren
ich glaube das habe ich im ersten video
schon erwähnt aber die nachfrage kam
halt verstärkt deswegen wollte ich hier
auch nochmal aufnehmen zum thema
gewichtszunahme das haben auch
tatsächlich viele angst und sang er kiki
kann ich dadurch eigentlich zu nehmen
weil öl und fett und kann euch sagen
nein absoluten nein also sagen wir mal
in dem jetzt ein thema für jeden tag zu
euch was sind das 40 kalorien das
wirklich bringt er mich ja also vor
allem aber auch wichtig selbst wenn ihr
gerade irgendwie abnehmen möchte eine
ernährungsumstellung macht selbst dann
ist es sogar förderlich weil ihr braucht
die gesunde nährstoffe grad bei einer
diät also nehmt doch dann erst recht das
schwarzkümmelöl ein wie gesagt also
diese 40 kalorien am tag also da müsste
schon über die stränge schlagen und
immer donuts pizza pommes essen und dann
macht das schwarzkümmelöl da eigentlich
eigentlich gar nicht
geben das ist es ja vor allem super
gesund gerade wenn euch irgendetwas
fehlt dann nimmt auf jeden fall
schwarzkümmelöl damit ihr euren körper
alles gibt was verbrauch zum thema da
noch eine sache weil gestern meiner
mutter telefoniert und die meinte auch
sehr hatte halt probleme und auch nicht
nur sich cobo hat ist das auch na das
ist ja auch nicht so viel reden muss
jeder hat irgendwann mein leben darm
probleme und nehmt das schwarzkümmelöl
und da also das habe ich jetzt bei
meiner mutter und bei hanser gemerkt
nach wenigen tagen schon seit er war
wirklich habt ihr da erfreulich
wirklichkeit darauf eingeht aber so
etwas einfach so sondern legte hier
besucht hatte ja und das ist super
wichtig so per wichtig jetzt fragt ihr
euch natürlich auch du erzählt so viel
gutes über das was mit den
nebenwirkungen eigentlich ist
schwarz-grün wirklich so ein
naturheilmittel da gibt kaum
nebenwirkungen ich kenne auch mal ein
gewisses
okay du musst nicht mehr zum arzt einen
einzigen nebenwirkungen die ich kenne
und die auch so bekannt ist ist dass er
aufstoßen könnte am anfang daher nimmt
das gerne ein auf oder nach nach dem
frühstück also nicht auf lärm wagen
möglichst und dann sollte auch
eigentlich nichts passieren oder fällt
ihr noch was ein auf der ducati
schließlich auf jedem mal man könnte es
auch lehrern waren ich hab gerade falls
irgendeiner probleme mit dem magen habe
dann stößt man halt ein bisschen auf am
anfang habe das ist das kleinste problem
man bedenkt was man für positives alles
hat die waagschale ist ja so übrigens
faktor der das einnehmen und wir haben
es jetzt so geregelt schon seit über
einem jahr das ist einfach neben dem
nachttisch den haben und dann kann ich
bei der gelegenheit auch mal springen
dosierer zeigen das ist nämlich super
eröffnet quasi den deckel und zack kommt
euch der springen dosierer entgegen und
ich tippe ich mache es jetzt einfach mal
vor
jeder hat seine eigene flasche sehen
komme ich da auch oft mit der lippe
trend einfach rein tippen ich kann gut
einschätzen wie viel dann esslöffel ist
ich nehme ein esslöffel jeden tag ich
persönlich und auch hamza vorm
schlafengehen einfach damit man es nicht
fertig
ja aber du kannst du auch mal kurz und
sprint-ass ihrer eigentlichen kummer der
springt jedes mal ja jedesmal
jetzt runter
geht nicht mehr sitzen nicht kaputt ist
nicht einfach zurück dank viele kunden
gestört aber es ist nicht kaputt einfach
nur dran drehen gut ist genau ist eine
ausgeklügelte technik finde ich geil und
hilft wirklich auch gut zu dosieren man
sollte schwarzkümmel übrigens nicht
erhitzen gerade bei mir im bereich
rezepte also nie für warme speisen
verwenden gibt das gerne träufelt es
über euren salat sehr gerne oder gibt es
so wie ich in die goldene milch rein
wenn ich mir die ab und zu mache wobei
ich bin der fan von kurkuma extrakt
verlinkt ich auch gerne in die infobox
dann gerne auch dadurch dass durch das
fed cook um ihn besser aufgenommen wird
schluck rein und fertig also mega
praktisch glaube ihr merkt wir sind 100
millionen prozentig überzeugt vom
schwarzkümmelöl deshalb suche ich schon
so viel dass es dunkel geworden ist ja
wir haben hochwinter netz und einer auf
die andere sekunde so dunkel draußen um
jeden fall haben wir nach elf monaten
meine schwarzkümmelöl seife quasi
herausgebracht und das war auch ein akt
weil es ist nicht so einfach auch nur
ein hauch von schwarzkümmelöl mehr macht
die seife porös und trocken aber so ist
die formel perfekt die schminke mich
damit jeden abend ab also make-up alle
sympathische es gibt alles damit runter
und ja das verlegen ich euch gerne in
die infobox da bin ich auf instagram
auch ganz viel drauf eingegangen seit
sie dazu fragen habe dann schreibt
gebunden in die kommentare und ansonsten
sind wir jetzt noch dran ich sagte ja
thema schwarzkümmelöl begleitet und soll
uns auch noch das ganze leben über
begleiten schwarzkümmelöl beisammen ist
das nächste ding das sind nur prototypen
das wird auch eine reise bietet es noch
ein paar monate dauern aber alles was
gut ist soll auch seine zeit brauchen
und ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass
wir den schwarzkümmelöl markt noch
weiter revolutionieren werden mit eurer
hilfe ich meine ohne eure nachfrage ohne
vertrauen würde das alles gar nicht
zustande kommen und daher an der stelle
einfach mal ein riesen dankeschön an
euch und ansonsten wünsche ich euch ganz
viel gesundheit einen wunderschönen tag
und sage bis zum nächsten mal auf die
skizzen jeans
[Musik]